You might never fail on the scale I did,...
...but some failure in life is inevitable.
It is impossible to live without failing at something...
...unless you live so cautiously that you might as well not have lived at all.
In which case, you fail by default.
Failure gave me an inner security that I had never attained by passing examinations.
Failure taught me things about myself that I could have learned no other way.
I discovered that I had a strong will...
...and more discipline than I had suspected.
I also found out that I had friends whose value was truly above the price of rubies.
The knowledge that you have emerged wiser and stronger from setbacks...
...means that you are, ever after, secure in your ability to survive.
You will never truly know yourself or the strength of your relationships...
...until both have been tested by adversity.
Such knowledge is a true gift for all that it is painfully won...
...and it has been worth more than any qualification I ever earned.
So, given a Time Turner,...
...I would tell my 21-year-old self that personal happiness...
...lies in knowing that life is not a checklist of acquisition or achievement.
Your qualifications, your CV are not your life,...
...though you will meet many people of my age and older who confuse the two.
Life is difficult, and complicated, and beyond anyone's total control,...
...and the humility to know that will enable you to survive its vicissitudes.